Okay,
well,
last time we saved theory,
uh,
from the clutches of nap and Michaels,
and we did so by saying that there really is a difference between language and
speech,
uh,
ad that's a claim that I want to continue investigating and today's concluding
lecture.
Um,
but in the meantime,
uh,
you know,
when,
when I say we saved very,
uh,
you may well be asking by this time,
well,
okay,
so you saved it.
But for what I mean,
why,
you know,
we,
we began to suggest last time,
uh,
that in a certain sense,
especially in view of neo pragmatist claims about the agency of language and
speech understood to be one in the same thing.
Um,
in view of claims of this kind.
Well,
do we have to conclude that theory is impractical?
That that is,
that it,
it,
it can't have anything to do with pragmatist objectives now.
And so that too is something I want to worry a little bit about today.
Uh,
why do we bother to say theory literary theory?
Well,
it has something to do plainly with communication.
Speech,
as we said last time is unquestionably for,
uh,
that is to say we have made it for communication.
So the old frankly,
incredibly tired question,
how well do we communicate with each other is unfortunately in a way not
irrelevant to what we're trying to get at here.
I want to say a couple of things about what the French during the
existentialists period called La Delac community Castillo,
uh,
and,
in a way there they're not really on the same page with each other.
First of all,
I want to say that we actually communicate rather well,
congratulations to us.
In other words,
um,
I think that in many of the conventional ways in which people worry about
whether or not we can understand each other,
I think that many of those ways are actually a,
of thinking about the problem.
We're actually exaggerated,
uh,
my own,
my own feeling is that perhaps a good deal of the time we understand each other
all too well,
and that might be better in a way if we didn't have quite such an acute sense of
where each of us,
uh,
are coming from.
Uh,
it probably would,
would,
would improve human relations rather than the other rather than otherwise.
Uh,
and the,
and this may have something to do with what I take to be a certain measure of
bad faith in the ways in which we try to get together and raise each other's
consciousness.
Our,
our,
our supposition is that the whole problem is that we don't communicate well and
now if we don't understand each other's subject positions well enough,
as I say,
I'm not completely convinced of that.
Uh,
so there's a certain sense in which I say,
hey,
speech is great.
It's,
it's doing just fine.
Don't worry.
We're communicating perfectly well possibly to,
well,
uh,
so why on earth should theory come along and say,
well,
there's sort of a problem with communication.
Uh,
and the problem is this,
this,
this nagging entity called language,
which keeps sort of poking up through the communication process,
getting in its way impeding communication as the Russian formalists suggested,
uh,
all for the better as they saw it.
Ah,
that language does.
Um,
why should it matter what's at stake as nap?
And Michael's might say,
what's at stake in calling attention to the way in which language does impede
communicate.
In other words,
we communicate fine.
But what we really mean in saying that is we communicate fine for everyday
purposes.
Uh,
speech has a rough and ready efficacy and anybody who denies that,
as I say it simply exaggerating problems,
uh,
that may exist on grounds other than difficulty of communication.
Um,
so,
so speech speeches really fine up to a point,
part of the function of theory is precisely to interrogate the degree to which
speech in an unimpeded way communicates the level of accuracy and detail at
which speech can ever be expected to communicate.
These are the sorts of questions that we might expect theory to ask.
And if you say,
well,
I'm still not very convinced that that's an important aspect of,
of one's intellectual life.
I don't blame you.
I hope to have convinced you,
uh,
over the next 45 minutes or so that it's pretty important and a variety of ways
and that it's,
that it's worth keeping in mind.
But in the meantime,
just to start on this issue tentatively we can understand theory and of course
we began the semester by defining it,
by trying to distinguish between theory and philosophy,
theory and methodology,
perhaps even those sorts of uh,
approaches to literature that nap and Michael's call poetics.
Uh,
maybe even to distinguish between theory and hermeneutics because after all the
whole drive and function of hermeneutics is to discover meaning and there is a
certain sense as we have come sadly to realize in which,
uh,
theory is more interested in the way in which meaning is impeded.
Uh,
so,
uh,
it may be as we suggested,
as I say at the beginning of the course,
that theory,
if we're to get comfortable with it at all,
you know,
we have to keep in mind that it's not philosophy.
That is to say,
even though you're good at theory and you understand the purpose of theory,
you can still be a system builder.
That is to say,
you can still have a sense of,
of x of explaining that to her totality of things.
That's that philosophy needs,
if it's going to function as philosophy or his philosophy properly should,
um,
you can still as nap and Michael Osei and gauge empirically with questions of
literary data,
uh,
um,
summarized in such a way as to amount to what we call poetics.
You can do all these things.
Um,
and you don't really have to feel as though theory is somehow or another
standing on the sidelines,
uh,
sort of shaking his fist at you and wagging its finger theory doesn't have to be
understood as a watchdog.
Uh,
theory,
it,
at least in my opinion and not everyone agrees with me,
uh,
theory really lets us go our own way,
and simply reminds us that there are certain
limits or reservations that need to be kept in mind.
That one is perhaps why is to keep in mind,
uh,
as we think through problems of interpretation and meaning.
All right,
so theory I would define as,
and I've used this word,
negation a lot.
Uh,
I would define theory as a negative movement of thought.
Mapping the ways in which it is legitimate as opposed to the ways in which I
have suggested it's perhaps not legitimate,
but mapping the ways in which it is legitimate to be suspicious of communication
theory is an ad athetic will counter force to that which is commonly supposed to
be true,
posited as true.
And here of course one comes to the point spoken as true,
you announced,
articulated,
spoken as true.
So if that's the case,
why the fuss about language,
why do we so quickly narrow the issue down to language?
What I said last time,
uh,
about language and the relationship between language and speech may have seemed
unconvincing to you because it was so narrow.
Uh,
and I want to broaden today a considerably broadened the sense of what I mean by
language.
It seems to me that theory,
uh,
encourages,
measure of suspicion about the efficacy of speech that which is spoken as true
in three ways.
Last time I mentioned one,
but,
but now,
let me emphasize three.
The first and the one I did mention last time as the way in which language of
truths itself as sound.
In other words,
if we think that,
uh,
if,
if we think of the efficiency or functionality of speech as a medium of
communication,
we're forced to ask ourselves even as we engage in speech.
How and why it is that speeches so much burden in ways that are of no use
whatsoever to us for the most part.
Sometimes they are of use.
Uh,
one of the,
one of the pre frosh asked me last time,
well,
isn't,
isn't sound a reinforcement of meaning.
I told you when we did new criticism that all of you had done the new criticism
in high school.
That's the way you learned literary interpretation.
Well,
this was a perfect embodiment of a bright person coming out of Hud high school
saying,
interpretation just is the new criticism.
And I've been taught that sound reinforces sense.
That's what it says in Pierides handbook about understanding poetry.
Sound reinforces sense.
Well,
it does of course.
Uh,
and,
and on those occasions,
we can revel in the complexity of an intentional meaning or intentional
structure that is,
uh,
augmented by the way in which sound patterns are used.
But at the same time as the Russian formalists,
it sort of discovered,
uh,
working through materials that weren't perhaps so much materials like John
Donne's,
the canonization,
uh,
or texts of the kind that lent themselves to a met to a degree readily to the
new credit,
but to illiterate,
illiterate,
alliterative verse,
a folk lore and folk verse in the Russian tradition,
uh,
pro verse verse embodies in proverbs.
And what they noticed in studying these materials is that there is simply no way
of grasping a semantic purpose,
purpose,
having to do with meaning,
uh,
in the sound elements that are involved.
And I think that as we recognize the way in which there's a strange pull in our
spontaneous peaking speaking,
uh,
toward repetitiousness of sound,
it's not just that we all speak,
I am Vic pentameter without knowing it,
which by the cases,
by and large,
true.
It's not just that,
it's that there are,
there is an extraordinary amount of alliteration,
uh,
and,
and rhythmic determination.
And what we say Yaka Epson has an interesting point in linguistics and poetics
sort of about moment when we're,
when we're nearby and an accident takes place.
So something like that.
Um,
he says you could call a person in a situation like that,
anything,
but we call that person innocent bystander.
And there isn't,
we do is metric right?
A person has an innocent bystander,
not because that expression has any particular meaning or sematic valence.
He as over against other expressions,
but because it's catchy because it sort of sticks in our,
it sticks in our mind,
um,
as a alt perhaps for Nima,
Nima,
technical reasons,
it sticks in our mind.
Uh,
as a catchy,
um,
Eisenhower won the election against Stevenson because I like Ike is a more
efficient taught of sort of way of engaging with the repetition of sound than
madly for Adley.
Jaak Hopson doesn't go into that.
But I think an interesting political analysis could be made of,
as I say,
the greater efficacy of,
I like Ike and all of these and all of these purposes of or,
or,
or functions of sound or I should say appearances of sound in speech are what an
economist might call irrational.
You know,
they're there,
they're doing a job,
but it's not really a job of anything that we could call communication.
The job they're doing,
uh,
is,
is sort of a free spirited and the part of language.
It's just there,
uh,
in an arbitrary relation with the sematic pattern of speech so much then for
sound.
But it's not only that,
if it were only that,
if,
you know,
if literary theory,
we're only about the first two or three years,
worst worth of research performed by the Russian formalists,
uh,
privately,
we wouldn't be having an introductory survey course in the subject.
Speech is impeded by language in two other ways.
First of all,
I mean,
second of all,
I should say,
I suppose a speech is disturbed by the way in which language produces in what's
being said and uncontrollable semantic drift.
That's what I want to call it.
And that is the language.
The language of an utterance is crafted to say some particular thing,
but actually it was so sir in um,
in,
in a,
in a work of his that's less known than the course in general linguistics,
uh,
who actually published a monograph on the way in which you can find,
um,
uh,
acronyms of various kinds,
buried or embedded in Latin verse.
In other words,
there's meaning within meaning,
which can't possibly have been planted there.
And yet miraculously enough,
you can find it there.
And so you can recite a well known poem,
the one that we took up last time,
uh,
because it was the example given in Napa and Michael's against theory.
You can recite a poem while reading this,
uh,
slumber did by spirits seal.
I had no human fears.
She seemed a thing that could not feel the touch of earthly years.
No motion has she now no force.
She neither.
Here's North seas rolled round and earth Stier and of course with rocks and
stones and tree.
Now you can see that to write the poem and this way
is to perform an exercise,
which is essentially what Joyce is doing and Finnegans wake.
As a matter of fact,
uh,
as I transcribe the poem out of my text,
as you can see,
I transcribed it.
I kept,
I kept saying to myself,
you know what?
This could be in Finnegan's wake.
I was actually quite pleased with myself.
As you can imagine,
this could be invented because notice that I have used all words.
I mean there,
there,
there is nothing in these eight lines,
which is not a word.
Um,
I have certainly engaged in a certain amount of anachronism,
right?
But I have,
but I have also used punctuation and I have worked out ways in which this
discourse makes sense.
And I could have just left it at nonsense.
Twas Brillig and this lie,
they toves did gyre and Gimble in the way by at which,
which is another way in which language is affected by uncontrollable sematic
drift.
The point of Lewis Carroll's a famous nonsense verse is that we all think we
know what it means,
right?
Twas blusters and the slimy toads did a leap and frolic and the way,
so why we think that it means something like that.
Um,
but then,
uh,
but,
but it,
but sematic draft,
which is what Lewis Carroll deliberately introduces too,
it prevents us from,
uh,
in any secure way,
drawing any conclusions about that?
Well,
maybe I'm,
I of course am making no claims,
uh,
for this transcription of Wordsworth slumber.
Did my spirits seal at all.
But maybe this can show us the ways in which,
um,
there is semantic drift.
I mean,
let's say,
let's say that you're a person,
not really as Stanley fish would put it in the interpretive community to which
all the rest of us below.
And so you don't really know what a poem is and somebody recites in your
presence.
What I just recited to you.
Well,
you know,
if you were quick good writing and you transcribed the thing,
you might very well produced something like that.
In other words,
it wouldn't just be,
be spontaneously occurred to you that what Wordsworth wrote was what you were
hearing.
And that's because the kind of sematic drift that I'm talking about really is
inescapably present in any utterance that we make.
The utterance is not often mistaken because we're really actually good at
understanding context.
That's one of the reasons why the called problem of communication isn't as great
as people.
Sometimes climate is we're at,
we're really good at understanding context.
Hence we're not likely to go badly wrong,
but certainly there are occasions on which we go badly wrong.
I mean that's,
as we all know,
that's the irritating thing about spellcheck.
You put on spell check,
you write your term paper,
you don't bother to edit it and you turn it in.
It's full of howlers because of course the language is full of harm and Emond.
Spellcheck always gives the wrong word,
you know,
and you're,
you're in the soap frankly because of course your teacher is just kind of
slapping his knee and go far.
In short,
don't use spellcheck,
but spellcheck is,
but,
but spellcheck is a phenomenon that shows you the way in which sematic drift
permeates language all right now.
But it's not just that either.
There's a third way in which language impede speech.
Remember I said,
ah,
and so sir,
so Soren ever says this in so many words,
but he,
but,
but this is definitely what he means by long.
Remember I said that language long is a virtual entity because we could never
actually and counter it written down in any codified form.
Yes,
it is the,
the dictionary,
the lexicon,
right?
But that's only part of it.
And so far notice that we've only been talking about the lexicon when we talk
about somatic drift.
But in addition to the lexicon,
language long is a set of rules,
rules of grammar and syntax rules in by,
by means of which,
and only by means of which speech can make sense.
In other words,
language,
uh,
has this sort of bearing on the choices that we can make while producing speech.
But unfortunately those rules can be a little bit slippery.
Why don't we talked about the innocuous expression?
It is raining as an illustration of Yacob upson's six sets of the message.
We were brought up short for just just as an example,
we were brought up short by the metal,
lingual of it is raining and we suddenly asked ourselves,
what on earth is it?
In other words,
there's a kind of a group,
there's,
there's a kind of grammatical and syntactical permissability obviously and the
expression it is raining,
but at the same time we really have no idea it can lead us in strange
directions.
This it,
you know Jupiter fluvial is God
sort of deep sea?
Well,
the cosmos,
the clouds,
some of it is plausible,
but none of us,
none of it is definite.
And we realize that it is a kind of placeholder in the sentence that is not
doing its job.
And,
and believe me,
it's not just English.
As I said before,
it's a phenomenon that you can find in any language.
Even in the expression it is raining,
you blur as pregnant and so on.
Right?
In all of those expressions,
it is not doing its job.
So that's another way in which if we lean on speech,
we have to realize that we're in the presence of what the economist again would
call irrationality.
That,
that,
that and that has to do with the way in which predication works in language.
As I said before,
uh,
an assertion,
a statement of truth and assertion of any kind is the utterance of a metaphor
because the deep structure of any assertion is that a is B,
that's,
that is an assertion by definition but a is B and and and of course when that
construction is grammatical that in other words it makes what the Americans call
a Copula when the construction has grammatical,
well that's fine because we understand that the relationship between a and B is
not a relationship that's insistently one of identity,
that a connection is being made.
A connection which demand for example would call met Nimic in predication.
But the problem is that any sentence which declares that a is B met and
clinically that is to say as a grammatical proposition is at the same time,
if we simply look at the sentence for what it is a matter for and insistence
that a is B in the sense that a is a
a matter of for in other words,
which doesn't stand on all fours,
no metaphor does.
It has an element of what's called catechesis in it
and therefore in a certain sense as we read the sentence necessarily undermines
the sentences,
grammatical structure.
This is the point that demand is making and semiology and rhetoric that there is
a perpetual tension in any utterance between grammar and rhetoric.
There is no utterance.
That's not grammatical.
There's no utterance.
That's not rhetorical,
but unfortunately grammar and rhetoric are always rather openly or or or subtly
at odds with each other just in the way that metaphor and predication really
have to be at odds with each other.
In other words,
there isn't a sentence and which the rules of grammar and syntax are not sort of
subtly interfering with what you might call the rules of rhetoric,
the ways in which tropes,
in other words deploy themselves ways which can be distilled,
um,
uh,
in an understanding of what we call [inaudible].
So every sentence,
as I say,
is shadowed not just by the vagaries of sound,
not just by semantic drift,
but by the incompatibilities of grammar and rhetoric.
And all of that is implicit in what so sewer and his tradition call language.
Those are the ways,
in other words,
in which language,
if I can put it this way,
speaks through speech.
The ways in which anything that we say on any occasion is shadowed by another
voice.
We've understood this in social terms as box Tinian,
poly glossier.
We've understood this in psychoanalytic terms as the discourse of the otherness
of the unconscious.
We've understood this in purely linguistic terms as language,
but at we can,
I think metaphorically speaking,
understand it now.
Uh,
as well as a kind of speech language is on it is an unintentional speech
language is just that speech which we recognize having gone through the sort of
analysis that I've been attempting is just that speech which is not governed by
intention.
Keep in mind nobody,
no theorists,
nobody in his right mind would ever try to resist the claim.
That speech is intentional that we intend what we say,
not that and that's the way in which Napa in Michael's are right and give us a
bracing reminder about things where our skepticism is misplaced.
You know,
the idea that speeches is somehow not intended.
What,
what,
what could,
what could that mean speech?
Just his intention.
But I've been trying to argue that there is a speech,
the speech of language which is unintentional,
which is just there.
It can't be factored up.
It can't be Brat.
Well it can be bracketed but it cannot be set aside as though it were not there.
It will always come back.
It will always,
it will always confront us at some point.
If we take the arts of interpretation seriously enough,
if,
if in other words,
we really do bring some pressure to bear on the things that people say,
not just a pragmatic pressure,
which I think works just fine for most of us,
but a professor about a pressure that goes beyond the pragmatic and notices.
What's really in a sentence,
what's really in anybody's utterance now,
what this language speaks through speech partly as its origin and the way
language gets into something that you or I might say is a reminder to us that
what we say comes from someplace.
It has an origin and its origin is precisely language and the language and
language keeps saying,
Oh,
here I am.
You know your origin,
right?
The birth of what you're doing.
In other words,
way back before you discovered that language was useful for something,
right?
Remember what we said about,
about that last time.
You know,
you have to discover that fire is useful for cooking.
Fire is not for cooking or cave is not forward.
Dwelling.
A prehensile thumb is not for grasping.
You have to make,
you have to discover the ways in which this is the case and languages they're
in.
What we say to remind us that it wasn't always the case to remind us that it's
just the origin of a history of conscious expression.
During the course of which we began the never ending process of trying to master
language.
That's of course what it is to be a writer.
You've tried to wrestle language into submission.
All right.
That's,
that's,
that's the ambition of all of us.
Whether we're writing the great American novel or revising a term paper,
we're wrestling language into submission and we all know it's not easy.
I'm just trying to explain some of the reasons why it's not easy.
So language speaks through us as the origin of speech,
but it also speaks as the death of speech.
It's beaks.
In other words,
as the moment in which the purposeful agency of speech is finally called into
question in a certain sense,
undermine.
And so I think it's appropriate.
I think it's fair to call language again,
metaphorically the epitaph of speech,
the way in which in any given speech,
it's all the end of its own agency is inscribed Eamon as that agency is going
forward.
Now I want to,
I want to test this example and also show you a little bit more about the way
semantic,
not semantic drift,
but even more than that,
the perilous relationship between grammar and syntax and rhetoric,
syntax and rhetoric work.
I want to actually try out on you a couple of epitaphs.
If language is the epitaph of speech,
why not?
Uh,
why not talk for a little bit about epitaphs.
Now,
my favorite App Epitaph,
um,
uh,
by far,
probably,
uh,
well,
you know,
we won't,
we won't speculate about where such an epitaph might be found.
Um,
but if you,
but if and when you come across it walking through a cemetery,
it'll probably elicit a chuckle.
The gray on the gravestone.
It says,
I told you I was sick.
All right.
Now this is a very,
this,
this is a very interesting,
uh,
expression for a number of reasons,
for one thing.
And,
and,
and one should pause over.
This one can infer speakers speaking efficaciously not just one,
but many most obvious,
um,
uh,
speaker is of course,
and there's plenty of precedent for this.
And Emily Dickinson and,
and other writers,
uh,
and most obvious speaker is the dead person speaking from the grave.
You know,
there I was sitting in the corner,
oh,
those years telling you I had a headache.
You never listened to me.
Uh,
and,
and so on.
So,
so,
so that is the most sort of obvious identification of a speaker.
But of course,
the speaker could be somebody else.
And I'm not,
and I'm not introducing a measure of skepticism and saying this.
We just,
you know,
we,
when we posit an intention,
we just decide which of these speakers it is.
Uh,
the speaker could be an apologetic relative,
uh,
you know,
someone acknowledging that they hadn't listened,
uh,
and,
but with a sense of humor.
And so putting in the voice of the dead person.
Um,
the complaint,
uh,
I told you I was sick as a form of apology.
Yes,
I know you did.
And unfortunately,
uh,
I had to go to the grocery store,
and so,
you know,
uh,
[inaudible] and so that to,
can be the speaker.
Well,
on the other hand,
it could be either as the dead person or as someone simply moralizing over the
grave,
which is a frequent habit of the 18th century.
So one of my periods,
so I'm familiar with it.
It couldn't be a philosopher.
I,
you know,
saying,
well,
you know,
I,
this is the human condition.
And I kept telling you,
I published 13 books and the whole,
the whole purport of which was,
ah,
I am sick,
right?
I'm Dostoevsky's underground,
underground,
man,
I am a sick man.
I'm a very sick man.
Well,
let it get worse.
You know,
I mean,
it could be,
it could be in this mode that a philosopher is moralizing over the grave,
or it could be a cultural critic.
It could be someone,
you know,
in a kind of an allegorical mood in scribing on the gravestone,
uh,
the death of culture,
you know,
culture sort of civilization has been in a bad way for a long time.
And here.
Finally it lies.
Uh,
and the way to communicate this would then be,
I told you I was sick.
A civilization has ways of letting us know that all is not well with it.
Uh,
we didn't pay any attention,
uh,
and here and here is the result.
Okay.
And I would say that all those ways of reading the epitaph,
um,
are consistent with hermeneutics that they're there.
They're consistent with,
uh,
with the way in which we can,
we can try to come to terms with the intention of a speaker.
But suppose we say that language must be [inaudible] itself,
uh,
in this utterance like any other,
what would that be?
You see,
that isn't just a question of sound.
It is a myth question of sematic drift.
In this case,
it's a question of are suddenly coming to understand the sentence in a way that
perhaps no individual speaker would want to give it.
It's an allegory precisely,
cleverly introduced by language about the inadequacy of speech.
That's just the problem with speech,
isn't it?
Again and again and again,
I tell you something and you don't listen.
All right.
No,
that's the problem with being a lecturer.
That sort of,
I told you,
I told you I was sick and you know,
and,
and you've,
oh,
well he's,
he's,
he's just joking.
Um,
and,
and so it is,
uh,
according to the allegory introduced by language at the expense of speech with
speech in general,
it's an allegory about the limits of communication because that's after all what
the speaker and you know,
insofar as there is a speaker and scribing this expression on the grind
gravestone is concerned about this person sitting in the corner complaining
bitterly about nobody ever listening to her or to him
is actually an algorithm is telling us that that's the way speech is.
Speech in other words,
has its limits in a sense.
Then when I say language is the epitaph of speech,
we realized that if we understand this utterance as an allegory,
it is precisely speech that's lying here.
The end,
as I suggested of speeches,
powers of communication as announced or declared by language.
Well,
let's try another one.
Here lies John Doe probably,
you know,
uh,
the,
or epitaph,
I mean,
supply your own name.
But,
uh,
John Doe here.
Here lies John Doe.
Well,
now consider,
well,
it's not even pause over the speaker there.
Let's,
let's get immediately to the problems posed by language.
And the first place John Doe obviously does not lie precisely here.
Alright?
He doesn't then.
In fact,
if you think about it,
it's all together possible.
The John Doe could be absolutely anywhere except precisely here because where
are the sentences?
We know John Doe not to be all right.
He could be any place else,
as I said.
All right.
And so any appetite is there for a self declared cenotaph an inscription on a
place where the body isn't all right,
which of course tells us a lot too about the arbitrary nature of language.
Language does not hook onto the real world.
It doesn't hook onto the body.
The one place where language is not is on the body.
The one place where language is not,
as on things,
speeches on things,
a speech can be inscribed on a piece of rock.
Okay.
So here lies John Doe,
except not here any,
but here,
which is why,
of course the interest of the word lies is so interesting.
They sorta the,
the utterance is a lie.
All right,
John,
but it's not John Dahl who lies that just that just read.
I mean it poor John Doe is just lying someplace,
right?
John Doe is not lying.
Hi,
it's language
that's making speech lie all right?
And it's,
and,
and it's not yet on a,
on any number of levels.
All right?
As,
as we've seen.
And so it's a funny thing about epitaphs,
they really do bring tour and,
and this has been noted by certain authors writing in the tradition of what we
loosely call deconstruction.
Um,
the appetite is,
is,
is a particularly fruitful a locus for the study of the ways in which language
challenges undermines,
displaces speech.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and as I say,
these two examples show more or less,
more or less the way that works.
So speech lies,
you know,
everywhere except here.
Speech,
I don't mean here,
speech,
speech lies because it can never stop being language.
And therefore we can never really possibly mean exactly what we said.
We can mean what we say,
but we can't mean exactly what we say.
I mean that that's probably the most common sensical way of putting the matter.
Uh,
um,
when Stanley Cavell poses the question and the title of one of his books,
must we mean what we say,
you know,
he is actually offering us the possibility that maybe that's not the be all and
end all of speaking.
You know,
that the speech act situation is more complicated than that.
And sure,
we all have,
uh,
it add heart as an objective to mean what we say,
but at the same time and speaking were performing,
we're acting as the neo pragmatist would suggest.
We're doing all kinds of things beside meaning,
uh,
and that really needs to be taken into account.
Uh,
even an understanding what speech can do,
let alone let alone and understanding what's beach can't do.
And so,
uh,
the,
it,
it's plausible to say that yes,
we can mean what we say,
but,
but it's a question whether and date.
It's a very insistent question,
whether we can mean exactly what we say.
Now.
You ask,
you ask,
you must ask,
because after all it's been our,
it's been our constant guide.
You ask,
does language speak in Tony The tow truck?
I mean,
I,
I know this has been on your mind and so of course we have to,
we have to address it.
Um,
I think there are a few interesting things to be said about that.
I,
I spoke earlier in the semester about the way in which the parade of the
vertical on the vertical axis of that vertical access called I,
you know,
as you read the text,
there it is.
Oh yeah,
Uh,
sort of out of luck car out of luck,
Indian feminism.
However you'll let the fallow go center right there.
I,
right.
But now,
you know,
I as never the first words spoken by an infant,
that,
that's,
that's another lesson of lock on.
I mean,
I as I,
as what you have to learn how to be,
maybe to put it in Judith Butler's terms,
uh,
and uh,
so that I in so far as it is this incredible upright pillar.
And Tonya,
the tow truck is a promise of precisely agency.
The promise of the kind of identity which stands up,
right?
Uh,
which is a successful simulacrum of what is seen in the mirror at which then
develops into what Freud called referring to the way in which infants began to
get their way in the world,
His Majesty,
the ego.
All right.
That,
so the eye has that function.
But as I say,
it's an,
it's a story about friendship and the I disappears.
And this too I think can be communicated as relevant to the infant in ways that
is that,
that,
that at the functional level of language that can't really be called speech.
For example,
the friendship exists between P and toe.
Knee.
Ah,
Oh ah,
Oh one before the baby says I,
it says,
oh,
oh Oh oh and that,
resonates in the friendship of bumpy and Tony y r o because Tony is stock,
right?
Antonio's natural response to being stuck would be,
oh,
all right.
And along comes bumpy and oh,
not only recognizes the problem,
but it takes care of the problem right now,
on the other hand,
the problem of self,
the problem that's caught up in this vertical,
I,
um,
comes into focus for the infant as the awareness of otherness.
So that which is alien,
that which is that,
that,
that which is sort of irreducible to the self becomes,
begins to come into focus and a way of expressing this is to say
e,
which is perhaps in some way or another,
a mask or Simulacra
of Hee Hee,
Hee,
Hee.
And I think it's for that reason that the two antagonists of the story,
the ANA assimilable others who do not help our called speedy and Nieto and other
reds,
that sense of that sense of otherness.
So that which is it intractable that which,
that,
which they cannot be sort of reduced effectively to self is I think articulated
in ee,
ee,
ee.
In other words,
what the infant speaks is not speech as it,
it's language.
All right?
If you want to hear language and speech,
just listen to a baby.
That's why nonsense verse has such appeal to young children.
They're still hearing language.
It's like,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's a way of putting,
you know,
Wordsworth's intimations though.
Do you know their,
their,
their steering still hearing that,
you know,
mighty waters rolling evermore.
They're,
you know,
they're,
they're hearing all I'm,
where we're all hearing speech,
you know,
they,
so,
so the infant as,
as,
as I say,
ontogeny recapitulates phylogeny the history of the human species is a history
of coming to terms with speech,
mastering speech or I should say perhaps mastering language.
Well,
so it is in the individual,
the individual who is hardwired isn't he for language Hass must somehow or
another Russell that hard wiring into what we call speech.
So the first thing we hear and an infant and maybe what is most predominant and
stories for toddlers and in nonsense verse is language,
which,
which you don't reduce somatically.
You don't parse it somatically.
Sure.
I've just interpreted it in into a kind of meaning,
but it's,
but it's a meaning which,
which,
which comes simply from the observation of feelings,
uh,
and noticing what children actually say on,
on,
on actual occasions,
which can't really be called speech,
but is rather a kind of experimentation with language dragging itself towards
speech.
But not anything that one would ever really confused with speech.
Partly an imitation of what is heard in the adult world.
That's where you get,
uh,
oh,
but when the adult occasionally says,
um,
there's nothing like the investment in it that there is in the child for whom it
is very often the first articulate sound.
All right.
And it is,
and it is the encounter with otherness and the Ma and the attempt to master it,
master otherness as in Freud story of Fort De,
um,
that this seems to be,
uh,
expressing.
All right.
So,
uh,
so much for Tony.
I just liked to confuse,
to confuse,
I'd like to conclude,
I'd like to conclude with three theses.
It's v once what you have to speak very carefully or language of truth.
I had to say very carefully,
three feces,
right?
Uh,
and I,
and of course I made a mistake just before I won.
I want,
I didn't want to say confused did I?
And notice that and notice that confused was not just anything getting in the
way of communication.
It was precisely what I did not want to say.
I mean precisely.
I mean I got to set anything else buttons,
but I said confused.
That is the fraud Insulet that I've been talking about.
Well anyway,
three,
three theses about language.
First,
it never makes sense.
Language does not make sense.
It's arbitrary.
It is a system of arbitrary signs that are not natural signs.
You make sense,
not language.
You make sense by invoking and intention.
That is to say by having an intention and wrestling language into speech that is
commandeering language for your purposes.
Language doesn't make sense.
You make sense.
Language in itself.
Secondly,
he says nothing about reality for the dust because it is a system,
a code,
a system of arbitrary assigns you.
And I want to put it this,
I want to put it two different ways to show you what's going on.
You come to terms,
as we say with reality,
and it's to say you find the words for reality as you grasp it.
Another way to put it is you figure it out.
In other words,
you come to understand what languages I figured it out.
But of course,
in rhetorical theory,
figure is precisely a figure of speech you bring to bear figures.
Just as you come to terms,
you bring to bear figures on reality,
you figure it out.
And finally to,
uh,
adapt and expression with which you're probably familiar.
Oh,
conclude simply by saying that the road to reality is paved with your
intentions,
be they good or bad.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].